yeah welcome to this video playing demo
05 from the Netherlands and the tower
and then playing the strange move h6
maybe we get to the position where I can
show what the idea of this movers I
think we get to it this is the idea it's
a I know it looks a bit weird but this
is in fact so common nowadays and the
French this early G porn la lunch lunch
along yeah I know how it is some another
I know the word LUN GE lunch it sounds
like lunch like having something to eat
and fifth okay maybe I'm pronouncing
this wrong again okay so I i got the e5
pawn and he took on c5 i got a five and
the sun is a kevin kevin wu teef here
compared to some other lines the only
difference is that i didn't play Bishop
e7 I have played h6 so g5 is actually am
protected very important Tim ok so just
queen to d6 or queen b 6 Queen B 6 mm
hmm maybe that's Queen f3 know let's
let's play 26 tech this protect c6 ya
black ass Warner a central pawn and now
has to Santa Paws against 0 so what some
pretty substantial material deficit the
central porn is quite a lot
so Jack of course I have weakened the
weekend king this is so this is clear so
on after his capture it's it's very
difficult to imagine that I can that I
can castle long okay maybe I need to go
Bishop c7 or something I I don't know my
king is so a bit a bit yeah there's a
cause for concern
yeah to be honest this can of line is
something that I would absolutely never
play in tournament chess I'm simply too
scared in this kind of position where I
really don't see a safe place for my
king I mean in some rather unimportant
blitz game I don't mind for once in a
while to have a bad king but in the
tournament game no absolutely nope so
how to protect this yeah 27 maybe yeah
it's a I forgot about that well walk
walk ah no no no I really shouldn't play
this kind of opening well my king is in
such bad shape came
I always get nervous I sit and I ask
myself why why didn't I play something
where I actually know where my king is
supposed to be okay is there some way to
to to play this at least this ruckus on
the gphone maybe I can can do something
the main problem is still my king great
just great
ah Jesus so Queen takes rookie successes
an instant loss
well so is there some way i probably
lost in many ways the absolutely only
idea is that then I have some Queen f4
Bishop f2 cannot counter play but um
this can only work if he blunders
something else when you can just play
night age 64 for starters or Bishop b5
if there should be five is very strong
just kills kills all play you should be
five maybe if there's also some direct
win 90 95 my twin directly but I move
like Bishop b5 is strong the queen is
attacked yeah okay maybe you can can do
all that so very very likely that he can
Queen f4 Bishop e7 shaky a rookie sound
check King c8 even that wins everything
wins
check ok
between a for checkin then maybe then I
can take Quincy for my have I thought
you could just like King h1 but maybe it
doesn't really matter so possible
really such a slow move what I don't
understand anything here cool shakes hmm
i have a hard time to understand that
what is the threat and i don't see the
threat Queen age six on what no
I do tendency move though average this
is a really strange move yeah okay come
on I have quite quite substantial which
an advantage so i can check before to
return something
Fisher Queen chief Bishop chief Florida
I don't really know I'm talking to some
some sense check check time morning
check check I could have taken the check
check check grah unhurt game drawn yeah
I mean I was so so lost here I do want
to do that and this is completely dead
disposition we can never have a news it
i roped you to it I didn't say move I
mean I was so irritated look you two is
probably really unnecessary but yeah I
didn't see a move yet I wasn't even so
sure what white is threatening here
maybe he's threatening nothing I don't
know the computer says cohen-chang Queen
III King age one check now this do this
is his line the King can just go here
it should be too i can try it's a
complete completely crazy completely
crazy kiya this this is good for black
his his pieces off side yeah it's just a
just completely completely insane
they're taking on g2 probably was not
working but i didn't see a movie really
i just wanted to do something something
something drastic check yeah he's
putting it on the board is probably not
using check the engine I'm always using
the engine its brief analysis 212 m yeah
to get some some help yeah this is this
kind of line I'm escaping check check
and nothing nothing happening really
yeah it was it was a completely lost
position that this is no question but
it's um it was really a really really
hard alright i hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching